what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series where we break
down the most powerful characters and
comics in terms of their origins and
powers and this week we are venturing to
the demonic corner of the marvel
universe and discussing one of the many
versions of the devil that marvel has
given us mephisto so mephisto was
created by stan lee and john besimon
first appeared in the silver surfer
number three in 1968 now the inspiration
for mephisto is a demonic character from
german folklore called mephistopheles
who is basically an agent for the devil
who facilitates a deal between his
master and the hero of the story a
figure named faust which of course is
done in exchange for the hero's soul now
as for mephisto's in continuity origin
we don't really know the exact details
because after all the thing mephisto is
most known for is his dishonesty but
there are a few different possible
origins that have been offered over the
years for instance mephisto told thanos
his origin was tied to an all-powerful
entity that once possessed all the
infinity stones and that he not only
created that entity but also destroyed
it when it realized how evil mephisto
was however once that entity willed
itself out of existence mephista was
resurrected as the rest of the marvel
universe was created another version of
mephisto's origin centers on the elder
gods who ruled earth eons ago once one
of the elder gods a tomb forces the rest
of them to basically leave earth or else
be consumed the residual energy of the
elder gods become the hell lords of the
marvel universe including mephisto and
yet another possible origin for mephisto
is that he was actually the first
deviant the celestial's ever created so
like i said lots of possible origins but
we don't really know for sure which one
is true nas for his powers mephisto is
one of those characters whose powers are
so vast that it's hard for them to be
quantified into a list as he can pretty
much do whatever he wants so with that
in mind as we go through his powers keep
in mind that this is by no means an
exhaustive list but first although we
aren't really certain of the specifics
of his origin one thing we do know is
that mephisto has been around for eons
and that's because he's immortal even in
instances when his physical body is
killed mephisto will always be born
again within his own realm now most of
mephisto's powers stem from the fact
that he is a master of manipulating
magic which is why he frequently finds
himself at odds with another of marvel's
most powerful magic wielders doctor
strange now one way he frequently uses
this ability is by shape-shifting into a
variety of forms which he's quite adept
at doing having been able to fool the
silver surfer into thinking he was
frankie ray also known as nova the
herald of galactus who of course is a
character with which the silver surfer
has extensive history and knows quite
well and this is only one example of
mephisto's ability to create convincing
illusions as doing so is crucial to his
ability to trick others which is pretty
much his bread and butter since he's
basically a demon and all now mephisto
is also able to look into different
realities as we see when he tells peter
parker the various outcomes that await
him in different realities when he's
trying to convince him to make a deal to
save his aunt may which of course we'll
come back to you later on he can also
influence the behaviors of others like
when he basically caused everybody
living on a city block to start
committing crimes like theft vandalism
and arson he can also cause people to
forget everything they know and
basically melt their brains furthermore
because he is such an adept magic user
he can grant magical abilities to others
and one famous instance of this is when
he imbued victor von doom's mother with
vast magical potential but did not grant
her control over those powers and this
incident with dr doom's mom is really
typical of how mephisto's dealings
usually play out so what happens is that
cynthia von doom whose people are
basically nomadic summons mephisto to
strike a deal to give her people a
permanent place to live mephisto gives
her magical powers and she goes to the
castle of the baron that ruled over the
land and then delivers an ultimatum to
give her people the land they deserve or
she'll simply destroy his castle when
one of the guards laughs at her she
fires a bolt of magic atom which
basically mortally wounds him but before
he dies he returns the favor and cynthia
wanders into the woods and then dies
herself with mephisto claiming her soul
now another famous example of mephisto's
underhanded dealings is when he cures
johnny blaze's adopted father of cancer
in exchange for johnny's soul but kills
him days later in a motorcycle accident
now he then bonds johnny's soul to
another demon known as xerathos and
curses him to an eternity as the ghost
rider and so to circle back to our
earlier mention of mephisto's dealings
with peter parker in a particularly
famous storyline called one more day
that spider-man fans just can't seem to
let go of mephisto heals aunt may from a
terminal illness but it comes at the
cause of altering peter's timeline so
that he and mary jane were never married
and in fact mary jane forgets that peter
parker spider-man and harry osborne
comes back to life and from this we see
that mephisto is capable of actually
altering reality itself now although
mephisto typically prefers to avoid
physical confrontation in favor of
defeating his opponents by outsmarting
or deceiving them that does not mean he
is not formidable in battle we don't
have a lot of instances of mephisto
showing a physical strength but one such
instance is when he was seemingly able
to knock out she-hulk simply by
backhanding her which really isn't that
impressive when you think about it now
on another occasion he was able to
handle an avengers team of captain
america wonder man black knight and
tigra without breaking a sweat even when
he was in a weakened state and mephisto
has also been able to use his magical
abilities to produce a powerful blast of
energy that was strong enough to one
shot the silver surfer which is
incredibly impressive given how powerful
the silver surfer is now in terms of
durability mephisto can really only be
harmed by weapons of a magical or divine
nature he survived blasts from the
silver surfer doctor strange and the
human torch who can produce as much
energy as a supernova another important
thing to consider is that mephisto rules
over his own realm which he typically
refers to as hell and which looks pretty
much exactly the way you would think
hell would look and it also serves the
same purpose to basically torment and
torture souls but the biggest reason why
this is important is that within his own
realm mephisto's powers are amped to the
point that he's basically omnipotent the
longer he's away from his own realm the
weaker he becomes hence the reason why
sure he fought the avengers and he
defeated him but it's not that
impressive in the grand scheme of things
in comparison to what he can do so he's
battled thor and survived being pummeled
with mjolnir and remarks that thor would
never be able to defeat him as he could
never truly perish and mephisto was
actually able to grow to gigantic
proportions and literally crush thor
like a bug with his bare hand he also
survived a blast from franklin richards
who's one of the most powerful
characters in the marvel universe but it
should be noted that this was when
franklin was a child so he wasn't really
at his full potential still given the
fact that franklin richards is a
universal constant and a universal
reality warper this is still a pretty
incredible feat now the list of things
mephisto has been able to do in his own
realm is really too long to list but
just to go over a few he was able to
take out the silver surfer and doctor
strange and we're talking classic doctor
strange which is way more powerful than
the current version but most impressive
is by far the fact that mephisto was
able to battle galactus to a stalemate
now galactus is one of the most powerful
entities in all of marvel comics and
feeds on planet's first nourishment and
in fact he had just fed on a planet
before fighting mephisto so not only
does mephisto match him in terms of
power but the battle between the two of
them threatened to tear apart all of
reality had they not been stopped you
know we should cover that story mephisto
fights galactus yeah we need to cover
that that's the most clickbait title
ever so just by that feat alone we can
tell that mephisto is well beyond omega
level and one of the most powerful
villains in marvel comics so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace